Trascrizione: Valentina Ultei
Revisore: Piero Cavallo
Alzi la mano chi si ricorda
del passaggio tra lira ed euro.
Ah, bene, bene.
Beh, un po’ di mani alzate le vedo.
Ecco, noi non eravamo neanche nati,
ma oggi abbiamo vent’anni
e siamo qui per essere ascoltati.
Anche se non ci ricordiamo della lira.
Viviamo in un'epoca complessa,
davvero incasinata.
Però questa sera vogliamo provare
a sciogliere un po’ di questa complessità,
parlando delle nostre esperienze
come giovani della Generazione Z.
Chi siamo?
Innanzitutto la Generazione Z, o Gen Z,
è composta da tutti coloro
nati fra il 1995 e il 2010.
Siamo quelli che chiamano
“nativi digitali”.
Noi siamo il risultato di una società
sempre più frenetica.
Veloce.
Iperconnessa.
Competitiva.
Ci svegliamo e ogni santo giorno
veniamo bombardati da notizie angoscianti.
Dalla fine del pianeta.
Alle pandemie.
Alle guerre.
Sì, perché questo telefono
è la nostra finestra sul mondo.
È inutile girarci intorno:
i social media hanno conquistato
un ruolo sempre più importante
nella nostra generazione.
Ormai conosciamo addirittura
i nomi dei figli della Ferragni
e i gossip di tutta
la famiglia Kardashian.
Ma con questo telefono
abbiamo anche dei poteri pazzeschi,
con tanti effetti positivi sul mondo.
Noi della Generazione Z
ci informiamo meglio,
abbiamo un pensiero critico
e politico più forte
e opinioni più complesse
rispetto alle generazioni passate.
Noi, ad esempio, non caschiamo
in link truffe o bufale online,
come invece capita ai nostri genitori.
Mi scoccia dirlo, ma la tecnologia
porta anche effetti negativi.
Parliamo ad esempio dell'isolamento.
La nostra generazione è la più isolata,
perché rispecchiandoci negli schermi
e nelle vite degli altri
rimaniamo soli con il nostro riflesso.
Appunto, isolati.
Isolamento è una parola che abbiamo usato
e abusato negli ultimi due anni.
Il lockdown è stato un periodo terribile
per tutti quanti.
Specialmente per noi.
Le nostre vite,
che erano in piena costruzione,
si sono ancora più spente.
Abbiamo però oggi ritrovato
una spinta fortissima,
un’energia,
un coraggio di fare e di agire.
La nostra generazione non si arrende.
Noi non ci arrendiamo.
Facciamo anche attivismo e spesso online.
Però questo a volte
ci rende più fragili, più esposti
e può causare stress o ansia.
I problemi di salute mentale
sono la triste caratteristica
della nostra generazione.
Saremo anche i “nativi digitali”, ma siamo
anche la generazione più solitaria.
Triste, vero?
Pensate che ad oggi,
la seconda causa di morte
fra i 15 e i 29 anni è il suicidio.
Risentiamo delle turbolenze del mondo.
(Suono di tamburi)
Ma tu, come stai?
Onestamente non lo so.
Ho 21 anni, studio, scalo.
Sono nato a Verbania, sono zeppo di amici.
Tuttavia, mi sento spesso solo.
Non sono mai stato una persona
particolarmente felice.
Sia chiaro, sono sempre stato
abbastanza malinconico.
Tuttavia, da un paio d'anni
non sto più bene.
Il lockdown ha rimesso in discussione
tutti i miei punti fermi.
Ed è appunto da lì che...
soffro di ansia e depressione.
E tu, come stai?
Anche io sto male,
ma so benissimo perché.
Perché io ci vivo qui.
E non intendo solo a Verbania.
Intendo proprio qui, in questo pianeta.
I miei amici, i miei genitori mi dicono:
“Sara, sei fissata”.
Ma non è fissazione questa.
Soffro davvero di attacchi di panico.
E tutto questo per colpa della eco-ansia.
Che non c’entra niente
con la raccolta differenziata,
o con le posate biodegradabili
o gli spazzolini di bambù.
Ma c’entra col fatto
che noi stiamo pagando il conto
di ciò che è stato
e non è stato fatto per la nostra terra.
E tu, come stai?
Io sto male.
E non ricordo
manco più il motivo.
Ho solo 16 anni,
ma mi sembra di camminare al buio,
nella direzione di qualcosa di incerto.
In questo momento vedo il futuro
con la forma
di un grosso punto di domanda.
E tu, come stai?
Io sono arrabbiato.
Ho 27 anni e non mi capiscono.
Trovo solo lavori sottopagati.
I miei genitori
mi dicono di accettare tutto, tutto.
Qualunque cosa, qualsiasi.
Per loro è più importante
la forma che la sostanza.
Ignorano quello che provo.
Non mi chiedono
che cosa voglio fare veramente.
Pretendono che diventi
esattamente come loro.
Ma io non ci riesco.
Io non riesco né a studiare né a lavorare.
E non è per pigrizia, credetemi.
È che non mi sento ascoltato, capito.
Non mi sento compreso.
Oggi siamo qui per questo.
Siamo stanchi di stare male.
La lotta per vivere bene
è appena iniziata.
Perché dopo questo TEDx,
le cose dentro di noi
e dentro di voi devono cambiare.
Vi possono sembrare delle banalità,
ma non è così.
Noi abbiamo realmente bisogno
di prenderci i nostri spazi
per stare bene.
E non intendo bene solo fisicamente,
ma anche bene mentalmente.
Abbiamo bisogno di smuovere le emozioni,
anche quelle più scomode, come la rabbia.
Sei arrabbiato?
Ci sta.
È normale.
Anche perché quello che sentite stasera
dalle nostre quattro voci
è solo un briciolo di tutto quello
che esiste là fuori
tra i giovani della Gen Z.
Non ignorateci.
E non abbiate paura di noi.
Anche se è difficile,
caotico, confusionario.
Noi ne dobbiamo parlare.
A modo nostro.
Proviamoci, qui, questa sera, adesso.
Come?
Con una semplice domanda.
Facciamo come si fa in chiesa.
Ma anziché scambiarci un segno di pace,
proviamo a scambiarci un sincero
“Come stai?”
Ciascuno con il proprio vicino.
Come stai?
- Come stai?
(Vociare del pubblico)
(Applausi)
Ecco, ripartiamo da qui.
Grazie.
(Applausi)